[Musique]
c'est une forteresse l'une des prisons
les plus sécurisées de france qui
accueille les détenus les plus dangereux
comme youssouf fofana
l'ex chef du gang des barbares tony
meilhon le meurtrier de laëtitia qui la
démembrer ou encore aït ali belkacem
l'instigateur de l'attentât du rer à
paris en 1995 dans le jargon
pénitentiaire on parle de gros profils
est ce pour éviter de les croiser toutes
nos demandes de reportages ont été
refusées alors ce jour là nous
accompagnons le député joaquim pueyo
les parlementaires peuvent y entrer à
tout moment sans prévenir
accompagné de la presse depuis son
ouverture en 2013
l'établissement s'est fait une
réputation l'agression de deux agents de
la toute nouvelle prison de condé sur sa
théâtre de nouvelles agressions le
détenu a agressé les surveillants à coup
decker enfer nouvelle agression ce matin
au centre pénitentiaire de condé sur
sarthe dans l'orne une arme fabriquer de
la frapper les surveillantes
sérieusement baissé agression violence
les nerfs des surveillants sont mises à
rude épreuve
[Musique]
pour mieux comprendre
direction le quartier d'isolement cinq
cellules sont occupés par des hommes
particulièrement violents est prêt à
tout ça c'est la cellule d'isolement dip
pour des détenus qui pose problème des
problèmes de comportement
et qui vont pas utiliser le matériel
comme arme contre le personnel même si
quelquefois il essaye quand même de
démonter des objets le danger est
permanent alors fabien revêt cette
combinaison d'une dizaine de kilos pour
se protéger mon souvenir le plus récent
c'était une plaque chauffante chauffé à
haute densité
gfr recevoir sur le visage donc sur le
coup on prévoit pas l'incident sur le
coup donc automatiquement il ya beaucoup
de de stress de peur et puis mes parts
compte en même temps pour pouvoir agir
dans la seconde tissu quoi tous étaient
douces équipe logiquement
ouais
il est l'heure de livrer leurs pas
[Musique]
nous restons volontairement à l'écart
pour ne pas créer d'incident youssouf
fofana se présente
tranquillement ce jour là aucune
agression
le fait d'être nombreux le fait d'être
équipé parfois ne donne pas envie de
fresnes vraiment les choses malgré cela
certains vous avez beau être équipé vont
continuer le passage à l'acte donc en
vont continuer à agresser donc est ce
que c'est que c'est notre quotidien
oui c'est notre vigilance on travaille
tous les jours pendant cette prise en
charge
mais c'est il ya on peut pas baisser
notre garde ne pas baisser la garde face
à ces hommes qui n'ont parfois plus rien
à perdre et cette spécificité du risque
vient d'inciter le garde des sceaux a
créé un nouveau quartier entre ses murs
dès 2017 une unité pour détenus violents
de 17 places pour des sommes en attente
de jugement
il ya des affaires de terrorisme et de
radicalisation
sans appréhension le parlementaire va au
contact lui qui fut autrefois directeur
de prison à fresnes et fleury mérogis ce
jeune homme de 22 ans a été condamné à
sept ans de prison après son retour de
syrie un viol en dormant selon les
autorités alors quand vous allez surtout
de la prison
quel est le projet c'est pas la france
reconnaît martin égalité fraternité ça
c'est des mots de valeur d'accord mais
c'est que après techs pour mieux la
mettre en garde
c'est comme ça que ce détenu ok tu es en
syrie qui partagent en réalité
l'idéologie de dèche
on l'a senti non seulement il sort dans
deux ans
et s'il change pas son état d'esprit
c'est quelqu'un qui peut être dangereux
pour la société française dans le
bâtiment où il est ils sont très peu de
détenus donc là et ne peut pas
influencer là où il est actuellement
je pense que la direction de
l'établissement à bien mesurer le
comportement de ce détenu qui peut
effectivement être influencés par des
détenus plus violent et plus radicaux
que lui c'est donc tout l'enjeu de cette
nouvelle unité
aujourd'hui avec 100 détenus seuls 50%
des cellules sont occupé l'établissement
faut donc accueillir ces nouveaux
profils de pensionnaires regarder des
personnes radicaliser s'était passé en
côte est d'origine mais il gardait des
détenus violents qu'il faut restructurer
accompagner sa saison on sait le rôle de
scène de cet établissement atteint
condition d'y mettre les moyens en
hommes et en matériels selon les
syndicats qui réclament un vrai projet
d'établissement pour mieux gérer la
violence
le dernier qui a agressé à condé sur
sarthe il est parti sur un établissement
c'est une patate chaude qu'on s'envoie
d'un établissement à un autre parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à les gérer
faisons des structures hyper sécuritaire
avec des moyens des hommes qu'on puisse
gérer ces détenus pour pouvoir voir
d'autres établissements on y mettra des
détenus qui veulent se réinsérer qui
veulent essayer de profiter de cette
peine
et voilà tout le monde s'y retrouvera à
ce jour huit pour cent des détenus sont
radicalisés
création de cette unité pour détenus
violents fera donc grimper les
statistiques au nom de la sécurité de
l'état
[Musique]